[Music]
before we start this video i want to
mention that only 21 of you have
subscribed so if you enjoy the content
please consider subscribing to support
future videos hey everyone welcome to
another installment of harry potter
theory in today's video we're going to
be discussing the harry potter world and
the fantastic piece world
more specifically we'll be discussing
how the two interlap the fantastic beast
films are of course prequels to the
popular harry potter films but one thing
worth mentioning is that after we
received the last harry potter film
there was a significant hiatus before we
got the first installment of fantastic
beasts in fact deathly hallows part 2
came out in 2011 which means that we had
to wait a whopping five years for our
reintroduction to the wizarding world on
the big screen and a reintroduction it
certainly was in 2016 we finally got
fantastic beasts somewhere to find them
the first installment of the five-part
film series that introduced us to a very
different wizarding world one that we
weren't quite accustomed to
it highlighted what the wizarding world
was like in a different era in different
parts of the world
and placed an emphasis on all sorts of
new and never-before-seen characters
creatures and places
we saw the wizarding world in america
for the first time
creatures like nifflers new magic new
protagonists and even a new antagonist
the first film was an entirely new
magical experience showing us so many
unfamiliar things in a world that had
become otherwise so familiar
two years later in 2018 the follow-up
film came fantastic beasts the crimes of
grindelwald crimes of grindelwald was
able to continue on the path the first
film had laid introducing us to so many
new concepts and ideas however they were
also able to interweave aspects of the
magical world that we were already
familiar with aspects from the original
harry potter films this was a good
strategy to try and reel in and
captivate audiences that were
heavy-hearted over the veritable lack of
old harry potter content the content
that we had grown up with despite the
efforts of warner brothers each of the
fantastic beasts films came under heavy
scrutiny from their magical fan base
mainly being criticized for a plot that
seemed a little all over the place
however the negative attention was duly
noted prompting big changes for the
three films still to come in the
franchise negative reviews and weak box
office receipts of the whole series was
something which warner brothers noticed
quite suddenly raising serious concerns
about their plans to launch five series
of spin-offs warner brothers has now
shown a great deal of confidence in
giving the third series with a great
deal of effort not to replicate the fate
of the previous films the negative
attention forced filmmakers to
reevaluate their strategy
and actually push the film's release
date back so that they could take extra
time to rewrite the screenplay the
result the secrets of dumbledore part
three of the fantastic beasts franchise
which will be released shortly in april
of this year one of the most compelling
aspects of the fantastic beasts
franchise to me is that while all the
events of the film are occurring there
is so much else happening in the rest of
the wizarding world the first fantastic
beast film took place in 1926
the second 1927 the next sometime in the
30s and i'm assuming that last will take
place in 1945 when grindelwald and
dumbledore are expected to have their
long-awaited final battle this gives us
a 19-year timeline but what is perhaps
most interesting about this timeline is
that so many significant harry potter
events occur in these same years in this
video starting from the beginning in
1926 i'm going to be diving in and
taking a look at what significant harry
potter events occurred during the
fantastic beasts timeline let's get into
it
kicking things off for the bang there
were several momentous occasions in this
year december 2nd merapi gaunt just days
away from having her baby arrives in
london poor pregnant and homeless to
raise money she sells karakticus burke
one of the founders of borgenenburg the
priceless locket of salazar slytherin an
old family heirloom burke offers her 10
galleons which meripee happily accepts
31st of december marapi gaunt
heartbroken staggers up the front steps
of wool's orphanage in london the matron
mrs cole takes her in and she has her
baby in the hour maraby gives
instructions for her son to be named tom
marvolo riddle
in honor of his father and his maternal
grandfather and dies lord voldemort is
born
19th of march a book launch for
fantastic beasts and where to find them
is held at flourish and blots in diagon
alley albus dumbledore was a huge
proponent of the book and upheld that it
should be a staple at hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry which it became
1928 morphin gaunt tom riddle's uncle
returned to the gaunt shack from his
imprisonment in azkaban only to find his
father marvolo gaunt dead and sister
gone
6th of december hogwarts keeper of keys
and grounds ruby's hagrid is born to
giantess mother fred wolfer and wizard
father mr hagrid 1931 15th of may
hogwarts herbology professor pomona
sprout is born
1935 hogwarts professor and later
headmistress minerva mcgonagall is born
to which mother isabel ross and michael
father robert mcgonagall in fantastic
beasts ii the crimes of grindelwald we
see a younger mcgonagall who appears to
be in her 20s or so however this is not
consistent with what jk rowling had
revealed about mcgonagall in the
original series
originally rowling stated that
mcgonagall started teaching at the
school in 1956 at the age of 21.
given that fantastic beast 2 takes place
in the year 1927 it just doesn't really
end up this must be a different
mcgonagall bertie bott the inventor of
bertie bott's every flavoured beans is
born in this same year 1938 august albus
dumbledore who was at the time a
transfiguration teacher at hogwarts
visits the troubled young boy tom riddle
at world's orphanage and invites him to
study at the school
later that same year tom marvola riddle
starts at hogwarts and is sorted into
southern house
1939 minister for magic hector foley is
ousted from office and is replaced with
leonard spencer moon
fully was ousted because he did not take
the threat that was grindelwald
seriously his lack of response to
grindelwald's for the greater good
regime was publicly questioned which led
to him being replaced by the more
proactive leonard moon in this same year
the muggle world becomes engaged in the
second world war
1940 rubius hagrid begins attending
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry and was sorted into gryffindor
house
1941 mr hagrid magritte's father
tragically passes away
1943 june 13th tom riddle opens the
fabled chamber of secrets containing the
basilisk of hogwarts founder salazar
slytherin upon opening the chamber
several students are injured and myrtle
warren aka moaning myrtle is killed
rubius hagrid is framed for the attacks
by riddle and is subsequently expelled
barred from magic riddle murders moaning
myrtle after extracting information
about horcruxes from hogwarts professor
horace slughorn and subsequently
transforms his diary into his first
horcrux in august tom riddle travels to
little hangalton and murders his whole
family for what he perceived as the
abandonment of his mother
those killed include tom riddle his
father tom riddle senior his grandfather
and mary riddle his grandmother
riddle's uncle morphin gaunt is framed
for the attacks by tom and is
subsequently sent to azkaban
while murdering the riddles voldemort
also creates his second horcrux marvolo
gaunt's ring
1944 tom riddle begins his final year at
hogwarts and is named head boy
secretly his close friends start
referring to him as lord voldemort
marking the official beginning of his
transformation into his new identity
1945 devlin whitehorn who founded the
nimbus racing from company responsible
for the nimbus 2000 is born
tom riddle graduates from hogwarts
school of witchcraft and wizardry after
graduating he has turned down for the
role of defense against the dark arts
professor and subsequently vanishes to
europe in search of rowena ravenclaw's
diadem
in this same year the second world war
ends and dumbledore finally defeats
skelet grindelwald which has a large
impact on both timelines
1945 is the year that we assume the
fantastic beast films will end as a
defeat of grindelwald in that year
should serve as the climax to the film
series
however i suppose there is always space
for the film series jumping forward in
time after his defeat perhaps even
delving into the 50s and 60s even if
only for a short amount of time
whether these harry potter events will
actually be shown in the fantastic beast
films is up to warner brothers but i
think that it would be criminal not to
include tom bridle's character at all
i just don't see how the time period
could be purely coincidence and if
warner brothers want to salvage their
franchise after the scrutiny they've
received then bringing back a young
voldemort and maybe even hagrid could be
a great start did you guys know that all
of this happened over the course of the
fantastic beasts timeline did i miss
anything
are you excited for the secrets of
dumbledore coming this april let me know
in the comment section below
until next time remember understanding
is the first step to acceptance and only
with acceptance can there be recovery